aloha reject nation how y'all doing G
training the J train gonna check out the
last Jedi a deleted scene boy I cannot
wait to see this I hear it's a deleted
scene with phasma or some type of
alternate take that did not make it into
the film super deleted alright you ready
for this J I Star Wars channeled himself
no boys a fish oh yeah by the way
patient the day Shaffer Austin more
[Music]
or what disrespectful winner beam us
down but when your shiny neck was
threatened yes feel like a hog the
evidence for what with the base picture
and I know the truth when I put a gun to
your head you shut down Starkiller
shields now what the troops do if they
found out or your masters
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow okay so there's a definite
argument to be made for why they cut out
that scene I mean I feel like the CGI
really held it down
yeah they would have never have I mean
in terms of getting a more character
moment from phasma and having a little
bit more of a meaningful way to go out
that would have been better I think it
plays out a little bit more corny
I don't know that has anything to do
with the visual effects possibly playing
the fact they're not fully complete here
yeah but in terms of like the tone and
style it plays out a little bit more
corny I think it is a better way for her
to have gone out in terms of satisfying
fans a little bit more on giving phasma
a little bit more meaning well cuz it
has a character note in it and they
address something from the path dress
something from the force awakens which
is a good touch I mean she takes out her
own stormtrooper showing that she was
gonna go down anyway yeah and also this
ends in a wayward you don't know for
sure if she's dead or not yeah she gets
shot and blown away but she has a car
Mirko just in the impact but you don't
know if she's dead or as the as the way
the last Jedi goes like that [ __ ] dead
yeah I don't know as the movie itself
stands from my recollection of it anyway
where this would have truly fit in the
cut that came out I feel like there
would have had to have been a little bit
more with Finn and phasma to make this
scene truly jive yeah but yeah I do wish
we got something closer to this in the
actual movie it's cool to see that they
were thinking along these lines anyhow
yeah I'm not sure why they chose to go
with the one that we got in the last
Jedi specifically because as much as I'm
part of the fan base that did really
love the last Jedi I was onboard with
everyone going yeah F as was pretty
wasted in that film - anyway sit in the
fins storyline the more that I think
about it could at least have been smooth
door or finessed or just kind of altered
in ways it always stands out as the the
odd duck of that movie to me and I feel
like this kind of factors
with that too it's a more satisfying way
for her to go out this specific scene
it's not a personnal yeah it's not as
underwhelming the thing too is that this
actually relates to the themes in the
last Jedi also because Finn has had to
learn an arc of you know being truly
courageous and whatnot he's confronting
her about like hey I held you up and you
caved
I just don't think tonally it fits with
the way the last like 30 40 minutes of
the last Jedi plays out that's probably
the issue yeah it's like isolated or
random yeah like the whole tone even
when she goes um rebels go may remember
that lines in the Trisha movie it just
plays out plays out a little corny here
but the context of it works better yeah
yeah it's one of those lines where he
says it you're half like I and you're
half like all right even like the shots
of like because that kind of has like
Western touch to it yeah yeah it makes
it a little cooler but still even even
the way she goes out when he picks up
the gun and shoots her just like man she
sucks yeah why you took out a storm
troopers you know think of who her team
is though her squad all can't shoot and
they're like million of them and they're
not very effectual it would only stand
to reason that she's just slightly
better than I really wish that the
captain phasma and gwendoline christie
got got to shine in either of these
movies because as it stands well they're
just sort of a cool idea that you show
up and you're like you're just kind of a
punk i guess well the thing is that this
deleted scene too would have allowed for
the opportunity if it was in the final
cut for her to return for another one
yeah whereas opposed if she comes back
in the next one you're like what maybe
we should just keep coming back bring
her back is like half a robot cuz that
thing too is like he sliced her hand off
oh and that's the other that's the other
part is that's the you know the Star
Wars omage at the Marvel movies do all
the time she was cutting off the arm
that would have been a cool little
tribute as well
I mean she's know where your along the
lines of adore this actually gives
phasma a little bit of an actual scene
where she's being confronted who
believed that she turns on the troopers
some voice and I yeah you know get a
little teary in that one I this probably
would have been
better I think it with a little bit of
tweaking in tone this would have been
better patron of the day shout out for
Austin Moore Austin dude my friend
Austin Moore weird
this guy does he's like really cool Lego
Star Wars films that I've checked out
and this dude actually is putting
together another one that he asked me to
do voice work for I think John her me in
the bedroom recording for it yeah you'd
be a good amount of lines to do so when
that's out you best believe we'll be
doing a reaction to that so I can catch
my couple minutes to see ya how does my
voice match with the character I did the
Jedi ax that I did which takes which
takes to the gunner :
before I was really yelling are they
gonna use the ones where I was like
smoldering in a tent I hope he makes
like a fat like make a Lego phasma movie
that is like everything we want that
would actually be a cool way to do it
and honestly yeah I will watch that and
right now he's actually working on a
live-action Star Wars short film to a
fan film that he's working his ass off
so this is a dedicated Star Wars fan you
could check out his channel
we're subscribed to it disturb fan zero
seven one seven productions I'll even
put a link in the description box for
you buddy Lego Star Wars Jedi Hunt fan
film it's pretty sweet stuff so I'm
excited to be a part of the next Lego
Star Wars film it does write the sweet
alright guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
brother get notified every time one of
our vids is up and check us out on
patreon full-length TV show music video
reactions over there as well as weekly
Q&A is full-on video responses you have
a question and we do a complete video
response for an hour an hour-long video
response that's right David letter